i'll tell you what i don't like
is these [ __ ] covet tests the one
with the nose oh my god what a weird
feeling yeah here's the funny thing like
i did it but i got the blood
i didn't try to listen let me explain
something to you you don't want to put a
cotton swab in my nose dog
what happened i got angel dust coke thc
crystal
animal tranquilizers [ __ ] dust
[ __ ] pubic hairs
i smelled new work in the summer what
have a nice smell
coke heroin [ __ ] are you kidding me
when they did my nose
i remember our [ __ ] dust open up an
[ __ ] a little bit of dust comes out
nobody knows nothing you just take them
right
you i remember when i woke up dr line
was jizzling my nose and the sparks were
coming out of my nose and [ __ ]
i got it still i still got coke rocks in
those glams in there
so you stick a cotton swab in there and
they're to [ __ ] it up because you know
they're making a mistake
right so the grandmother's going to go
you didn't test positive for code
but you need treatment you need help you
got like 10 kilos in your [ __ ] house
who would go for that [ __ ] stupid
test and wait online